okay so this is the finale - korra
season 3 um considering how good it was
I provided you with a sheet of paper and
pen so you can just write your apology
right there and it was an excuse me
oh no it's actually pretty good okay
good then get right well got one and I
wanted about every piece of the saliva
stain paper but was it back no it's okay
so here's the fight face and I host what
no no it's fine cuz so many things I did
not see going in the certain direction
and I really liked it for that but now
that I know the direction it was going
out saying oh they could have done good
then a few other things to make it like
even even stronger but at the same time
no it's a tough emotions because like at
the same time like you know how it's
talking about let's not think it's not
very huge at those be like you know this
major major thing and it doesn't get
that way till the end and this Zaarly
and I fly like Superman how can you get
any more bigger but in terms of which is
kind of weird I got it a minute nope in
terms of like the characters uh
motivations and backstories and and who
they are stuff but with the ending that
they did it all came down to literally
like the last two minutes really in my
opinion because the ending is so kind of
emotionally ethically confusing but I
mean that a good way I actually exact
opposite of the season one end it yeah
this feels like an apology almost for
the season one ending like it's season 1
ended like this I still would probably
say season one's been the strongest
thing we've seen like but but at the
same time I mean honestly
ok here's the thing in fat season 1 it
ended this way we'd be like perfect this
is a perfect way to end it with this one
uh we don't entirely know what she's
going through or what they're setting up
so why we have a four
no no I know but that's why it's hard to
get like a grasp on it because it's like
wait what are they doing cuz they what
they're selling it won't be very good
it's unlikely I'm sure will be good but
I mean he'll like this season they're
talking you know the the spirits coming
in the change will be hard they'll be
difficult but we will go through it and
in the season they almost never address
it you know so it's hard to say well it
seems clear though that this season's
gonna be connected to the next seat yeah
it which was a nice surprise I was
guessing yeah this was ome then they're
gonna wrap up the whole thing with the
spirit world and the Sandman yeah so
that that's what I'm curious about and
yeah it is nice and like I said just
very it's a very empty ending for the
most part I mean not that nothing
happened but at the same time I mean
just yet you look on her face and she
just looks like something was really
taken from her and you're not entirely
sure what well there's love there's a
couple things one she can't walk no but
I mean all this chatter she's gonna feel
like she's gonna heal and get better it
just takes time it really looks like
something more was gonna take him from
her or me baby we're not talking about a
very patient person yeah
and we're talking about somebody who's
lost the ability to walk my guess is
she's lost some of her ability to
effectively bend particularly well or
avatar but that's a but they haven't
officially said that that's what so we
haven't said but that's what the poison
was supposed to help do well that that's
why I'm curious about what if cut they
say no should show you better she'll get
better and it's like they're just in her
like something is the asylees up the
other thing is one of the things that I
was thinking of when I was watching it
is she's watching um
Jinora become the next sort of airbender
the next egg it's just like yeah now
becoming literally kind of the next egg
and if you're the avatar there and
you've been sitting here for seasons
where everything rests on you and now
you're completely crippled and it's just
like everybody tells you it's okay
we've got this we're all right I'd be
sitting in that chair feeling kind of
useless in the moment like maybe I well
that's is like there's maybe happy that
life is going on for
but she also made me like well maybe
this is in maybe my work here is done
like you know what what I like about
this ending again but a lot of certain
depends what I gonna do it if there's a
lot of options which I like no not only
options but consequences freakin
consequences at last um and all shit
happens and it's not all wrapped up in a
neat little bow like Oh what and what I
mean Elite what I like too is that you
know I was talking about these villains
and how saying like you know it's like
the guy but main guy kya crummy but the
rest were just sort of like it kind of
you know Jitsu that they look who only
do cool things but there's not much
character to them and get by the end of
this it it felt right cuz there is such
this empty feeling at the end where it's
like yeah these guys want to do
something major but they're just they're
these four they're powerful but it's
just sort of like almost a for nothing
thing like all this stuff happen all
this chaos and it's kind of its like the
emptiness you get at the end of the Dark
Knight yeah everything the Joker put
over he's just a force of just chaos
there's like no real even meaning to it
yeah and it's all said and done it's
just like wow so for assholes you know
it's I get the same feeling when I watch
something like Wrath of Khan it's like
alright so one asshole caused all the
damage thanks a lot you know you nailed
it it's not this really complex
fascinating any various complexity to
the main guy but because he is just so
monotone and so you know it I will leave
the spirit world even when like his
girlfriend dies he's like you know oh no
well I can fly now um you know but I
don't like I weren't worried no it did
work and then because I think you're
right it's just an asshole it's just
yeah asshole I mean it feels it's like
stuff can't happen just from assholes
and it can feel so it feels even more it
in history's history's full of that yeah
John Wilkes Booth Lee Harvey Oswald into
that bus you know no way everything
aboard is gonna be like conspiracy
theories now thanks for that
I mean you know all of these assassins
of the guy who killed Franz Ferdinand
started World War one like entire Wars
and millions of people dead because of
one asshole
yeah no no that the keyword is just
asshole like it's not like these really
complicated like I said the main guy is
kind of complicated same way maybe the
Joker is or something but it's like it's
still primarily like what they said ah
nihilism basically yeah I mean it's just
some assholes and but it's like I say if
you told me at the beginning of this
season your villains are just gonna be
some assholes they're they're cool I
soaked up they're just assholes I feel
like what the hell is a Vuitton car they
had all these great villains but it's
like know that this seemed to work and
came together um
again it felt like almost a retread of
season one like to me they're almost
kind of like a mod where as Amon was
concerned with bending altogether as a
social justice issue these guys are just
concerned with the avatar and just
rulers in general but it's that same
theme they don't think I got that from
this the second day I was gonna say
season yeah there's hole sees it almost
feels like a rewrite of season one like
in some in some small way like you know
this whole season feels very much like a
and we could be wrong you know but it
sounds very much like they really listen
to the fans and said okay let's try to
really you know we know we got two
seasons now let's do what we can with
and what wasn't what the experts are
these guys is that just listening to the
fans it's they have the ability hmm
didn't know they were coming back I mean
if they left it on a weird ambiguous
note on season one that and
Nickelodeon's like we're done no more
seasons can you imagine the end of it
like man yeah the same you were just
like I'll wrap that too easily would be
looking it's like what would have downer
ending god this is so nice you know so
you never know so they had the
opportunity now to stretch this out then
given anything is attacked its militant
exactly um but uh know the things I was
talking about that they could have
possibly tweet uh what is that you know
the fight I did mine honestly especially
because it came after the death of his
girl
was damage than a Man of Steel no but
but here here's my couple things one is
that you know I let go of all all
attached oh there you are you gonna get
slammed oh thank you I thought the same
thing
I've let go of all worldly desires I'm
like but isn't wanting to kill the
world's leaders to bring about your
social revolution a worldly desire now I
can take it or leave it
um yeah I I would I saw that I was like
scratching my head because I was
watching it with my wife and I just
turned her I was like wait a second this
is would that be and she's like yeah you
know the only rationale is a weak one
but only rational I can think is like
she can in the mind say he can give it
up like literally not hated the rational
and I in a rational I've seen is that it
was a reference to his girlfriend who
just got killed
yeah so now he's got nothing left
holding him back I I guess it works I
still think that's kind of weird that be
like I've given up all worldly desires
as I desire to do this major yeah yeah
it was it was very weird but I would
okay I love had the relationship between
the two of them a little stronger I was
seen that's the only thing I was missing
was but good okay I'm sorry
well I was saying the only thing I was
missing was they play it up so much is
like oh when you were asking me oh I
love you and I'm like wouldn't we see
that I kind of really would have loved a
flashback episode we're kind of like
shows yeah um so that was but I felt it
was great voice appian great writing I
just kind of was like oh well they
obviously have this really cool
relationship I wish I could have seen
more of it like good god we thought
earth Queen death was I mean pretty
intense oh my god
I mean just like it was just a few
frames but you're just like
the pineapple under the sea Oh God
people have been making those even said
my favorites when Cora's like I'm brow
shaved up and like your eyes are bulging
and she's you know dying his tummy just
sees fudge oh my god yeah I love the
ones would spun about pointing laughing
coming up next but what I'll tell you -
this really dumb idiot moment for me I'm
watching that see again very intense
scene right she's chained up Platinum
DUP and um you know he went platinum and
the given of the poison as soon as his
face broken we saw a monstrous from
second would I know I got the same thing
no no no I can't be yeah for about maybe
two or three seconds I was like oh my
god greatest twist ever like oh okay
okay I'm like maybe that it probably
wouldn't have made sense anybody make
anything with made it easier for a
second out because I really owe ya is
the same reaction I was like um but I
think that's the point where I sort of
hit me - when you saw the villains of
the past I even kind of a week or what
like the one from the second CH I almost
say this when I saw the villains from
the past it a it hit home how much I'm
actually invested hmm now like I thought
there was a really cool scene but it did
make me realize this is all the
matically tide they're all political
villains mmm um well I
yeah I'd say for the most part ok the
job i evil spirit of death is just kind
of big be actual Eva Qaeda but the kind
of doom maybe not as much political but
I guess it's connected to the hones with
yeah I was thinking of a mom um I was
thinking of her uncle and then as I hear
there is this weird element to this one
like now that we've gotten past a number
of the spiritual elements well if you
think of the kind of doom as the
original spiritual element and he's
influencing the other three then we've
gone from spiritual which is what the
first avatar was about now - Korra where
it seems been a lot of politics
so but something about when I saw them
also allied up in there in the air
villains I thought these no they sorted
yeah the strangely count words because
they are different you know it's not our
web 2.0 you know it is like natural like
different villain kind of villain I
guess because they're just assholes
um but yeah the other thing I wanted to
point out - I really thought cuz to get
everyone on my facebook on for a CA you
just sees the finale all tears and feels
and so I swore somebody what's gonna
like one of my characters was gonna get
axed off and I'm and they were building
up like ago the sisters are like you
know just be careful and then the
father's like following my stuff I bet I
know the brilliance of counting the
early Greek yeah I really glad they did
I'm glad they didn't they didn't need to
go that route okay kill not for me
characters fight but there has to be a
purpose to it and they did not need to
and I'm glad they didn't um it wouldn't
been I can't think who they would have
killed all four I'm like that would have
been necessary to finish yes you had her
think the father was dead that's one of
the reason she was especially nuts going
after the bag either a great fight uh I
was on the best fight yeah I just get
better and better every season like it's
it's I'm sorry
I love avatar but like it's making that
fight at the end of season three in
Avatar just almost look embarrassing now
like it's just getting all know that
that fight is still awesome to me oh no
no it's awesome it's really awesome but
when I look at what they're doing now
like just the way the CGI has improved
over the past you know number of years
like cuz I did to me it's like you know
comparing like you know a modern show
with something like Babylon 5 which back
in the day it's like oh gee I awesome
and now we're just like Oh like well I
like something looks really good and it
has though the way to obviously uh but
no it's that kind of fighting was in
practically like every episode okay and
that the one thing when I got to it here
I finally just said well you fucking
stop it is when okay team avatar comes
there's the other bad guys you know
Malcolm Bowl and they're like you know
you go ahead we
got them I'm like okay I am so fucking
sick up we got them and then they're
gonna fight and they're gonna be okay
and if I or won't get character knows if
whatever it's I'm so sick of we got this
I've seen that fight and every episode
that I'm done they're cool but I am just
like they've seen in small soldiers
comprised entirely of cliches yeah it's
like they're you can't go out there I
have to it's too dangerous
no it's like they're having to trust me
they're well animated they're well done
but it's like dude why can we spend that
time knowing the couple knowing the bad
guy and his girlfriend why can we build
something more there it's like there it
depends on the fight this one though I
thought was really cool by the time we
got there I was just like I'm so sick of
just these guys always going at it and
doing their cool moves and stuff it's
just like Jones do something different
myself ending no and that was a good
twist having cut we all thought okay
he's gonna do the metal bending it's up
but it was lava bending that's great guy
so yeah that was a good fake out and but
it was also satisfactory like you know
what we're not could go this direction
we'll go this direction instead and it
was just as good so um
ya know I'm really I'm really intrigued
and like I said now that we got to the
end we don't quite know where they're
going I would argue some of the the
season depends on where they're gonna go
with it but I would say like I now kind
of see what they were going for uh and
it does work out and so the slow pace
was alright but they're still I guess we
gotta wait for season four but I mean
like why the fuck do we have Zuko in
that dragon
I mean what the hell is the point of
that you just answered your own question
why the fuck wouldn't you have Zuko and
that dragon I have on the fucking do
something you know and all this stuff is
serv built up and nothing really happens
with it so on the one hand I'm like well
that's a letdown on the other hand it's
like it's this big to be continued and
they're building up something and it's
like I don't not going to be the great
arbitrary the judge yeah well that's why
I'm saying so if I can't I mean I unlike
the other two seasons I can
like oh well this sucked cuz there's
loose ends I didn't tie up well it's
like we don't know oh yeah I have no
idea what's coming next season um so
yeah I'm more psyched for this season
than for I think probably anything since
the show started but yet you know it
isn't it fascinating how the other two
seasons you know again head Cora you
know hockey Cora you know I think she
has everything but then getting kind of
lost and not knowing then by the end of
each season she finds her way and stuff
here it's the exact opposite she's
everybody found their way but her yeah
you know she was actually very confident
and very good this uh and she gets
through it and then at the end she kind
of lost her way and we don't know where
it's going she doesn't know where it's
going and it's like that's so much more
fascinating and I will say this too
because we were talking about what we
should have had originally yeah well I
got stuck I'll say too this is just a
weird tying back to avatar cuz
everyone's always like you know oh and
it is so much better and stuff like that
but again I really like how they
emphasize like she has the moves like
she has the technique down because
that's how I we said in Avatar like
every time they're captured and chained
up and stuff like an avatar should be a
million ways out of this and stuff and
sure enough like which he's all planned
about that every day I mean she's doing
flips and kicks oh yeah no I'm like when
she's chained up in like bending with
her feet like you know I'm like yeah
that's the way I mean it's like I like
they really emphasize this like she's
got the skill you know it's the
emotional validation she was scouring
they always got the impression that she
was stronger but she was not mentally as
well that's why I like that was very it
was very switcher and she can go in and
out of the Avatar state like nothing um
you know very easily so I really like
that they there is that switch around ah
likes it what do you what do you think
are they going to just rewrite season 1
and have the next part be her spiritual
journey becoming whole again even though
that's kind of what we did in five
minutes at the end of season 1 are they
just going to kind of rep calm as me
like well yeah when you know I am better
I can't predict what they're going to do
which I like I
like to predict what they're not going
to do hopefully if they do a Dark Knight
Rises where it's like you know oh yeah
well she's just sort of you know
crippled at the beginning and whatever
but then after a few whatever gets a
robo leg and then you know goes back I'm
back I'm fine and all the emotional
damage went there's like no no no it's
not that I'm cool um then I had somebody
like string me up by rope and fix my
back just to get broken again and prop
back again like live literally broke in
and brought back um you know when you
put it like that you make the Dark
Knight Rises some ridiculous sounds are
stupid right weird um
I should lay off that but I can't damn
it starts to hurt you got Dark Knight
Rises I've got Man of Steel yeah when we
both have our Nolan fuck you um but I I
would like to see everything that was
set up in season 2 with the spirits
really come back big time in the fourth
season cuz honestly if cuz they're
building up like the earth came in the
the city is in ruin
I mean it's like this was not like oh
and we'll have people clean it up
whatever it's like it's what the hell we
gonna do like this is a big problem even
though and I serve on this confused you
know almost quiet ending there's a lot
of bad shit going on right now and I
hope they tie that in also with the
spears coming into the world uh I want
everything else just built up
particularly the spirits can be the new
UN I I want everything that was built up
from particularly the second season to
the first things I like Frieza consider
a total yeah yes season to me is a total
write-off well I like everything the
segways give us but it just doesn't have
anything really to do with the rest of
this anymore
yeah I like everything from the second
season in the third season uh that we've
discovered and that has been opened up
to come to a head in the four seas in
which case does that make seasons two
three and four the real trilogy here and
you just forget about season one it's
hard to say cuz then we always say
there's energy don't know it sees one
then like the Phantom Menace is that
like it's not it
no but then there should be you know
like five more seasons this is much
longer no we'll just go back redo the
first one it just make like every minute
2005 actual addition in this one Amon
shoots first yeah but no that's what I
would like to see cuz then a lot of
stuff they had a lot of problems I'd be
I was talking about the second 13 so a
lot this like really came together and I
even though it probably would have been
planned I would add tracer be like maybe
it was planned maybe it was our whole
time together cuz that is the one really
big letdown so far is that like I said
the emphasis that the change of the
spirit world calamity human world is
going to be really hard and it we get
the airbending fine but that that should
really be more of a side thing the
spirit I mean these are totally
different life or it's interacting with
totally different life forms and that's
just sort of push to the side and it's
more toys you can sell exactly so if all
of that sort of comes back in the four
season like all these things except
comes back I'll be like okay now I kind
of see it cuz they're saying things that
have gotten worse with our so it's like
let's see what that I will say this I do
feel like seasons two and three no
connect more together so I'm willing to
bet most of this was planned from season
two on I feel like I don't know maybe
I'm making it up a bit as it goes but I
feel like there's more of a solid plan
here than going from say season 1 to
season 2 yeah just his no connection
like except when they repeat everything
the court yeah right it's literally like
they just rebooted the story there so I
I'm hopeful like I know I want to see
what they can do and I think knowing
this whole I think they're pretty solid
the fourth one will be the last one um
you know and I think they seem to know
when they know they're beginning and end
you know like where this is gonna end
cuz
I heard them in the commentary they said
they'd like a show knowing when it's
going to end
you know when the seasons are going to
end and Avatar they knew was going to be
three so they they had that figured out
um and I think now knowing these
whatever these next two seasons they
have them back-to-back and obviously
that they continue uh I'm openly can't
really put something good together um I
think they can
oh yeah faith unlike you who should
still be writing that apology ticket
girl prodigy magician you car was great